don't have that background because you
don't have that history and as long as
loyalty is there first and foremost and
that you would treat man so you would
treat your men
as men don't wrong they have to be men
in the first place and by men I mean
actual masculine men they have to have
the right frame they have to have the
finances in order but
as long as they can see that you have
the right history you have the right
motive and then the loyalty is there
altogether
I think we could all agree near that
that relationship is now going to last
and it's going to be fruitful forever
what's more important a low body count
or loyalty
what's more important
I don't think I need to pick either one
they tend to be the same I'm gonna say
they kind of they go hand in hand
because if a girl has a higher body
count it's more baggage it's more
ecstasy has to deal with it's more at
like I hate this term but like Alpha
widows yeah I've never heard that it's
yeah it's basically like the x that the
girl can't get over but there's more of
them the more people she slept with I do
agree with certain points that you said
about game I do agree with body count
and I do I was raised on women shouldn't
get run through and I do agree with that
and I'll preach that to my daughters but
I don't what I don't agree with is
the perfect family the scenario the
greatest thing for a woman is when she's
standing in her living room the 30
people celebrating her
yeah for some people yeah for some
people that is that is their life goal
I don't think
I've got a few people in my family that
can't have kids
so that's the exception that's the
exception and that's an exception so
it's to say is to say she can't have
kids her life is any less fulfilled than
my other Auntie that has got that maybe
maybe but she's living her best life on
in foreign
I don't think her life is any less
fulfilled no it's not it's not going to
be no it's not going to be an illness
fulfill I mean technically it will be
thinking probably periods of her life
but she's one of the kids but but again
I mean that is the exception sort of
rule and it doesn't mean she can't be
happy but she's not going to be as happy
now that's just the sad truth of it
right but if if you're a woman I mean to
go back to your previous Point what
would a woman want more than to later on
be able to say that they're a
grandmother great grandmother with loads
of loads of kids load of people that
have come from them what will I know you
said that that's not every woman's goal
what goal would you say a woman would
value more than that long term that
Society has hasn't told her she should
have yeah
um like I wouldn't I want to cut the 30
grandkids 30 great grandkids down to
like eight nine because the cost of
living out here is crazy yeah that's a
lot of Christmas presents but the point
is the point is if women doesn't
prioritize a family she ends up unhappy
in the long term in general
like because this is when you survey
women because it's it's all fun and
games when you're still hot right and
you still look good right and you still
get attention from men but at some point
that goes away like no guys are lining
up to date 50 year olds yeah and you're
going to live to be 90. go ahead yes
sorry um we have that window so that's
why we want that commitment fertility
window yeah yeah so we need to
we need to optimize in that and try and
find that commitment when we're in that
window so then so women want women are
nurturing they want to have kids
naturally not all natural naturally you
do
but I believe the only reason why some
women will say they don't and I I
personally believe I'm yet to be
convinced otherwise is because modern
day social conditioning Society has
convinced you that's not your ultimate
goal but if you actually walk into a
dark room with nobody in there by
yourself completely quiet and ask
yourself what do you want what does your
biology want I think you know the answer
when you ask girls that are 18 and
they're graduating high school they all
want to be married with kids that's the
first thing they want yeah but who sold
them that dream
as well it's definitely not Society you
have feminism pushing you can get your
own bag female empowerment like I've
been told from the youngest age that I
can do whatever I want Society is
telling you that you should have this
big career yeah and make it on your own
and [ __ ]
it's not all you want you're just gonna
if you're gonna be like a a high up
lawyer with loads of money you may have
loads of money but you'll be lonely
because you won't have
your children you get a couple of more
holidays a year out of your money so
[ __ ] what at the end of the day what
does it matter to you if you've not got
a family that's ultimately what you want
to have children I mean it's the gift we
have yeah
you're breeding machines that's
literally what you're biologically
designed I know this but I want to ask
you guys something here now the LGBT
community yeah should be allowed to
conduct themselves how they conduct
themselves right so we more than likely
we're not going to get any kids from
that area yeah yeah now the women that
we're now telling go to work go to
career and stuff don't have kids late
now we're telling those women not to
have kids what do you think happens to
the human race when people stop having
kids
that's what I'm talking about so we need
a man and a woman to have kids right
right otherwise we need to continue the
human race and to touch so it sort of
cut you in but so it's going but on that
point people have got to understand that
what we're fed to believe we want and
what we want on a DNA level cellular
level are two different things and this
brings me back to the very point you you
all touched on earlier with regards to
what men are looking for in women and
what women are looking for in men now
this is just for anybody watching at the
end of the day the simple breakdown I
provide for people is if you're if
you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if I was to sit
here and break down a woman so for
example
I would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah right she's very very driven
she's got loads of friends around her
that love and respect to her family her
daughter pieces Highly Educated what is
every single man in this room thinking
right now
in what sense if I was to describe a
woman and start off and purely lay out
those
um attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the Aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women it is slightly different
in that
now if I was to say
he's
a great looking guy
chisel jaw
big dick
tall
why what does he do well thank you very
much yeah you've broke so the first
thing you want to know who is he what
does he do what his connections what's
his status right in society I think deep
down every single woman asks those
questions and if I was to say along with
those things
if I was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mum's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no goals trying to
hit him up what would you say now
get the [ __ ] away from me is what you're
saying
I always said we shouldn't say hypergamy
isn't a bad thing
hypergamy is designed for our survival
yeah exactly I don't want to date a bomb
like I I hope to God you guys don't want
to date bombs so you're saying guys
would date a girl who's bummy
well at least that's what a girl a woman
being a bum to us well we don't really
look at women as bums for us it's more
to do with your loyalty yeah and it's to
do with your attitude in life whether
you're arrogant whether you've got that
overly confident nature to us it's
repulsive but a woman having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal ultimately on a
DNA level and this is what most men need
to understand this is what we act on
it's Primal it's on a DNA level we are
ultimately after
good breeding stock so you need to have
and this is this is a woman's display of
good breeding stock good genes is by
having a great physique a beautiful face
she's youthful she's young she's within
that Peak fertility window
she does have a clock the sooner like
that that will run out and then she'll
she'll end up on the other side of that